you can walk into a school and you can
know in a matter of minutes whether or
not the culture is right and the school
is mission aligned
everything else flows out of that
good morning daisy may how are we this
morning good
our mission is to train the minds and to
improve the hearts of our students
through a classical content-rich
curriculum that emphasizes virtuous
living traditional learning and civic
responsibility good morning first grade
[Applause]
hillsdale charter schools are classical
charter schools and what that means is
they bring a well-rounded liberal arts
curriculum
great teaching
and a sense of mission and purpose
to average american
kids we start every day with every
scholar every faculty member reciting
our mission all together as a reminder
that this is what we came to do we came
to train minds and to improve hearts
good morning jacksonville classical
academy argonauts
all together the pillars of virtue
honestly persevere
[Music]
have a wonderful final day before spring
break argonauts
using the word classical encourages us
to remember that we're doing basic
things here
we're doing things that are common to
all human beings
that's a superb place to start
and so classical philosophy
is interested in what things are
and the good appropriate to them
the one thing that a classical education
emphasizes that other educations do not
is the learning for the sake of learning
in order to appropriately educate a
child you must speak to more than just
the academic part of a child it's not
just about knowing things education
should be so much more than that it
should be about the formation of
character and that idea was embedded in
early k-12 education
character formation forming a whole
human being this is what education was
understood to be back then
as you walk around the hallways there
ought to be
respect for teachers there ought to be
kindness towards students there ought to
be happiness and a sense of wonder there
ought to be activity and engagement and
discourse and the pursuit of knowledge
the pursuit of truth
the reason why i think classical
education is the best is because it
draws on a long tradition within western
civilization we give students a really
robust exciting rich education we don't
restrict ourselves to the minimum
standards of the state
we want to trace the greatest ideas that
have ever
been a part of the human experience
and so we read the great works and we
study the thoughts that have
been propagated across western
civilization in order to unpack those
questions what we do in government class
is we read the constitution
we read madison's notes on the
constitution we read the federalist
papers which gives the rationale behind
the provisions in the constitution
and we read the declaration of
independence which gives us the
political theory that informed the
constitution
these are 12 year olds that have now
read
the two most important founding
documents of our country in full and
they have their fully annotated copies
of them we are giving them a buffet of
the most amazing books of antiquity
looking at things that have stood the
test of time
when i'm going through
those tough texts or when i'm struggling
to read those novels
it is very
encouraging to know that i have someone
who's going alongside me with them
rather than clearing a path free of
those obstacles we want to be there to
support them and to show them how much
there is to be gained by overcoming
those obstacles but acknowledging that
the perseverance and the courage that it
takes to sit in that moment when you're
struggling
is so
beautiful and does more for the
character of their heart than
anything else they're going to learn in
that moment when you wake up in the
morning as a grown up and you look out
on the world and are worried or anxious
or concerned it's not your college and
career readiness that's going to make it
through the day it's your ability to be
optimistic to have faith
that things are going to go well to have
courage to make the tough decisions that
you know are right
they want to teach your children how to
think
they want to teach your children the
importance of who they are in the world
and that's very important that we do
that so that we can help continue to
grow and develop them to become
passionate people who are making a
difference in serving the country and
the communities that they live in
so how do you become what you become
practice
aristotle says you form your character
by making choices and especially the
hard choices are formative
in the end what we like to say is these
well-rounded human beings that have been
truly exposed
to a rich and deep liberal arts and
science education
they will be prepared to do anything
here at hillsdale college we're a
teaching organization
and the k-12 office is no exception
we teach
people how to establish and maintain
excellent classical schools focusing on
five areas
board governance school leadership
curriculum
classical teaching and school culture
the college now works with local schools
and provides them the background
information
recommendation even helps connect them
with the people who they need in order
to run these schools
[Music]
what they offer is a philosophy
resources a curriculum scope and
sequence to help guide teachers in the
carrying out of each school's mission
the primary work with hillsdale college
is teachers and how they can improve
their practice in the classroom and then
the curriculum right the curriculum is
the soul of the
of the school
when a school like ours opens hillsdale
sends a team of curricular experts
teacher coaches professors and those
folks spend about two weeks with the
faculty getting it ready to teach
they are absolutely passionate about
helping teachers in their classrooms
what they actually do is just offer
really good advice so not only do i feel
challenged as a teacher to be my very
best for these kids
but i also feel like i have the best
behind me
i can get on a zoom call and speak with
the people who are helping with the
literature the literacy in hillsdale and
i can be connected to different schools
in the united states and we're all
talking about what's going on in our
schools so it's really an amazing
all-around package of in-kind support
that we don't
pay anything for our job is to help the
schools be great and we ask them for
nothing and everything
in return our advice is free
but it's also really expensive because
all we ask in return is that you do an
excellent job
the k-12 initiative fills a huge gap in
our nation's education system because
what we need are thoughtful informed
people who are not just educated to be
money makers but who are educated to
become
fathers and mothers and leaders
[Music]
in an obvious way education is the
future
but it's also the present
[Music]
what we say to the young and how we
treat them
that's
as important a thing as we do in life
the most rewarding part of my job is
seeing lives changed
most of the families have come here for
a reason they want something better they
want something more complete for their
children we're providing an oasis for
many of our scholars it's a place where
they are
guaranteed to be safe they're guaranteed
to be loved uh and teachers who care
that to me
is invaluable i mean there's nothing
more important as a parent than to know
that you've given them that
one of the main reasons that i love it
here is the relationship between
teachers and students
students
what does service mean
here at treasure valley classical
academy i read to the littles
i read stories to them every single day
i get to meet them i get to interact
with them i get to check uniforms i get
to have conversations with them i get to
see the ones that are sad and i get to
follow up with them and sit down next to
them
and try to figure out what is bothering
them or what has gone wrong in their
lives
their curiosity their pursuit of
knowledge
the ability to help them to ask
questions that they wouldn't have asked
before those are things that they might
not remember but what i won't forget is
that to be pulled towards helping more
kids is why i ended up coming here
this school and the education that's
offered in this city will change lives
the work is so important that's why i'm
here
i don't know that i could do anything
other than this this is what i love and
where i belong
our ambition is to sow the future seeds
of liberty with the formation of human
beings
into citizens that will
nourish this experiment with liberty
that we've been bequeathed
if we can improve the schools
we will improve the future of the
country
and we will improve ourselves
then we can turn the tide
my greatest hope for our students
is that they will one day
look back
and say that they have
lived a life worth living
[Music]
and by that point
have had a direct role
in
perpetuating
the american experiment with liberty